23 and about a year out of ministry
school with no school debt since I work
four jobs and cash flowed everything so
I'm totally debt free I work at a
professional Screen Printing and
embroidery shop and volunteer for
Ministry making $20 an hour I work 45
hours a week at the shop and after taxes
I'm at about 30 36,000 a year this is
the most I've ever made but when I
listen to the show I'm often confused at
what you all say is a good income but if
you look at the uh the income scale in
United States 36,000 is is is obviously
on the low side uh but I love your
discipline that you actually have a
budget and that on that income uh
because you have no debt and you're
living on less than you make uh you know
look you're saving some pretty good
money there so uh I don't think you need
to be worried about getting another job
no but the answer to that is what job do
I go to next